well what's happening reject nation Greg
Albee here
John Humphrey here Andrew here we're
back in action people was a little sick
over the weekend but have healed just in
time to watch the Captain Marvel trailer
numero dos we are big football fans love
that love that sports can't you smell it
on us normally I say subscriber the real
rejects after a videos dumb but I wanted
to say subscribe you the real rejects
because we are so close to 600k just a
few hundred more were there and also
check us out on patreon I bet you've
never heard of a youtuber talking about
that over there we do weekly Q&A s John
does music video coverage and we also do
TV show reaction watch along for many of
shows that includes attack on Titan my
hero academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood Riverdale Gotham and
supernatural it's an awesome [ __ ] in
time like females in the world
transition let's do this trailer people
oh yeah check out and ruin the movie
source channel he's a good guy
so scrolls are the bad guys you're free
a race and noble warriors heroes noble
warrior heroes you're gonna have to
explain that
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory
[Music]
Parker better Wow
keep
[Music]
memories something in my past is the key
to all of this
you see that's a yes or no question
yes oh yeah
what you really are
[Music]
you come along
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
Wow
now I shall was pretty friggin Asik
Apted marble cat is here the cat's got
everything everything for the fans the
Easter Egg is comic book so here cat
the cat can we watch that again yeah
that's a lot of information dude pretty
sure it gets everywhere all the cops in
the first chair we're like you know we
gotta make this cleaner ladies bag
it's some really great music that's for
sure
[Music]
this design is so freaking beautiful
looks like a lot of energy I love that
line harder better faster the mask it's
like some Lawson spaceship you know this
this trailer is got me really appealed
to like the past memory stuff and like
the really grounded like as much as I
love the all the space stuff it's the
grounded elements actually look really
appealing but that don't have anything
with helmets to do that on this one
and this trailer makes it feel more than
ever that Jude Law's the bad guy you
know like I know that's been the hot
theory but especially that moment right
there her like it was like you look like
you're a bad guy
that's Roman he's in the trailer we
noticed him this time he's got the same
headdress in every bit go my nari this
this sequence is the one I'm looking for
the motor starter has that is bitchin
that looks like next-level [ __ ] yeah I'm
so excited to see this softer side of
their fury like the humor that they're I
mean it's a Marvel movie we know there's
gonna be humor in it but you know the
first trailer was more you know yeah
show us more humor alright before we go
into this I know normally for our videos
we really cut them up and do a lot of
inserts and everything like that but you
know people don't really care about that
when it comes to do trailers like this
they just wanted up and ready so if we
seem a little one smooth I apologize
let's just go into this raw version
after this jump cut I gotta say
something I don't know how people are
gonna take what I'm about to say right
now I don't think women should play
super I think there's something up with
her I don't fully believe her delivery
on the tough lines and it's just a
trailer so I gotta say that it's just a
trailer and I'm even if I don't say that
in a reaction usually when I watch a
movie I'm like you know what watching it
in the movie was much better than the
trailer and I usually walk away in most
movies and say that but the lines here I
don't know they feel like trailer tough
lines and oh there's something about the
way our delivery sounds like I don't I'm
gonna hear that toughness in her voice
that's kind of missing for me I feel
like all the body language stuff is
really evident but the delivery was a
little bit like feeling it there but
still looks great
I don't know like literally that's my
one only
criticism I have about it oh yeah I mean
my gut feeling is just that it might not
be a performance that cuts great into
what needs to be a Marvel trailer basic
yeah
feel like my hope is that you know in
the breathing room of the movie she
really comes to life because I really
love that first shot with her when she's
just summing it up for Sam Jackson you
know being like a minute
where should you know like an alien war
yeah you know who's back and forth for
me yeah yeah yeah Andrew I mean I don't
know but I would just say like that I
did like the banter at the end between
her next year yeah that was pretty good
but I mean visually it looks interesting
and I know we talked about in the first
trailer that they the directors said
that the tone they're going for in this
film is Top Gun and Terminator 2
Judgment Day and I get that I mean like
again with the action sequences of term
air - I mean there was just an intensity
you know different sequences so I'm
definitely noticing some of that too in
this so I mean I'm looking forward to
that point view and we got a cool little
Top Gun reference in there with the cat
it's name is goose so in the comics her
cat's name is chewy cuz she's a die-hard
Star Wars fan but they didn't want to
you know get people confused with Chewie
Chewbacca and all that so they just went
with goose thank God because I would
have thought this is canon and that is
Chewbacca version so every movie goers
and Easton they're like wait a minute we
just cross the Disney wildly confused oh
yeah I could be wrong but I don't think
well now I don't know if it's gonna be
in this trailer and a minute 45 the side
of his head appears the background of
one frame I was gonna say that was that
was I mean obviously we'll see what
happened to the film but I was one thing
I was looking forward to seeing you in
the trailer just some like some banter
between him and Nick Fury in there but
yeah I mean that betting scenes look
really cool too
everything everything that we're getting
here I honestly think looks really
amazing and I need to clarify this it
was really just a couple of lines that I
was talking about I feel like everything
else I heard was pretty great alright
before you like get on my freakin ass
about it they're like everything else I
heard today was pretty great yeah I mean
yeah it really has a couple lines like
most of the trailer is action and
you know different set pieces and stuff
and this really gets me excited for how
broad the world of the movie looks
because like they've been hyping up how
Captain Marvel is the most powerful
character we will have introduced us for
a change that way it does seem that's
the thing is like you think about all
the Marvel movies and I'm thinking like
Oh Doctor Strange is like out there but
this looks like out there in a different
kind of way again yeah and it does look
like from that last shot like yeah I
could totally see how this is the most
powerful person we saw yeah that last
shot was awesome I mean there's a Greg
and I can't talked about this to in a
while back but there's some parallels to
the first Robocop film in this in terms
of you know someone who's lost their
memory is like reprogram basically now
this kind of superhero if you will and
you know there's parallel events that
happen that trigger flashback so I mean
from that perspective you know I felt
that Robocop I mean we know Kevin Feige
uses diehard Robocop fan he's even
described that as the perfect film which
I would just agree with Kevin Feige on
it right um but yeah I mean that that's
a that's an interesting perspective
looking at this film and I think we got
to talk a little bit about Jude Law yeah
because I don't think so he's deaf with
a bad guy I mean they're definitely
doing as much as they can to hide you
know the character I'd actually be more
surprised if he's doctor there's only
two possibilities of which characters
he's probably gonna be playing it's
either gonna be Marvel which I thought
that's what they said in the press
release when Jude Law was hired it said
yes Wow Walter he was lost and and said
wait what yeah Captain Marvel [ __ ] or
he could be playing yon rug which was a
Kree commander in the comics and he's
the one you know they had there was a
comic I forgot which version of it but I
think he was holding Carol Danvers
hostage and that's basically were you
know the kind of the explosion that
eradicate the Kree eradication that you
know kind of hits her and that's how she
gets her powers that's what happened and
one of the versions of the comics but I
mean what what what see what happens and
we know that obviously it's definitely
gonna be like that in this every might
say I'm just saying it's
it could be one of those two centers
we'll have to wait and say hey I'm
looking forward to this film man I think
it looks awesome and I I feel like we're
gonna get and get a movie that's
probably gonna be something pretty
special especially for the MCU and just
comic book movies in general just movies
in general but there's something really
special at hand here and yeah this is
definitely the most exciting this is
entered to me that and that hand-to-hand
combat with that grandmas girl was
pretty impressive yeah I can move that
grandma I'm excited a support elder
abuse
all right well transition out show time
all right guys well what did you think
of this Captain Marvel trailer do you
think it'll be better than Wonder Woman
that is the only question that matters
we got to pit all DC and Marvel fans
against each other always you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons kind of suck and also check us
out on patreon we got [ __ ] over there
and your Gordon on the movie source
channel look up the charisma exuding
from his face right now you got to go to
it right away